up hey guys what's up so it's me again
one more time today because i'm so sorry
i forgot to do gme because i went for
amy from amc to triple q
because i wanted to show the correlation
and i just noticed that so guys i'm
posting a video only on jamie uh because
because there is no reason i don't do gm
today if i did the
rest of the stocks i'm usually doing so
jamie what do we have so it's pretty
much the same thing but uh let's do it
let's do it together so what do we have
we are having exactly the same kind of
situation which is a massive move up
that is following once again very well
the fib um extensions
projections and um and that is pulling
back so whenever you have a pullback you
measure it to know who is in control
okay and we are above the fifty percent
uh fibration at 138 which is telling us
that bulls and control on the long term
um
we could go once again even to the 120
levels 200 to the level bulls would
still be in control so what do we have
on the shorter term uh if i i'm gonna
send on the daily timeframe we're having
this consolidation that is exactly the
same we're having on sorry triple q here
guys and that is the same that we're
having on amc all right so we're having
exactly the same pattern that is uh
happening on those three stocks that
have
nothing in common i would say
except that uh you know traders are
are trading it i mean um you know it's
just the market is correlating with a
correlation equal to one usually which
means that every move is happening
together uh in the same direction
whenever um market participants are you
know not really
whenever there is no direction in the
market and here
um
we are in the same situation guys so
this is the reason why i am going to do
the technical analysis on all of them
but
the conclusion is going to be the same
if triple q drops amc will drop gme will
drop once again we have sometimes the
negative data that is taking place but
this negative data takes place only when
we are in a bull market so this is what
we are looking for so i told you guys
that on triple q
i got stopped at 339.5 so now we're a
little bit lower i don't really care
because i mean it was just a play that
then that i do on top of my uh you i
mean long term place i do some day
trading to you know cover the losses
of the long-term place that sometimes uh
take more time to deliver the the
profits we are expecting
so bam bam triple uh sorry gme guys uh
what is the situation here so like i
said we are in the same kind of
consolidation here the levels are 142
and 152 so we are in this tight range
for the past
eight days something like that uh today
as you can see we had a nice reaction
right on the support so once again how
to place your support whenever you don't
have exactly the same levels as you can
see i placed my support here why not
here just because here i'm having one
reaction here i'm having one two three
four five so
i mean this is where
most buyers
entered the trade and managed to create
a short-term reversal so this is the
level they're gonna keep buying so this
is where you have the support level
uh bam bam bam so yeah let's see what's
gonna happen guys we are still in this
tight range so
as you can see we had a close at hundred
and forty one point
four so once again for a bearish signal
to happen um i hope it will not happen
but unfortunately we are close to it we
would need to have a close you know
below 141.
so
triple q is dropping more since i did my
video that i posted just before
but we are still in a i would say
neutral area as long as we are above 200
338 and we can have some access to 336.
uh what can i tell you about gme guys uh
bam bam
yeah i don't like to see that
as you can see on the hourly time frame
we had this 200 period moving average
that was here
acting a little bit as support
likes
as support and here once again we went
through the 148 level i'm not sure why i
have this level here because it's a
breakout level
uh and we went through basically all the
moving averages together so that's not
very good to be honest
um
but once again as you can see whenever
we are in a disorganized move it's very
hard to really predict what's going to
happen we need we're waiting for a
signal i mean as long as we don't have a
signal
uh we're probably going to keep moving
sideways and a signal would be created
by a strong volume
in the same time as a breakout so this
is what we're looking for this is what
uh i'm gonna try to tell you whenever i
see it for now we don't have it
um
and yeah that's pretty much it guys uh i
can quickly show you as well uh
the usual
um
the usual stocks i'm showing you
so there is oil and silver so let's have
a look um once again i'm not making a
good day today guys
pretty bad actually uh yesterday was the
same so
you know
those days can happen but they cannot
happen too often right that's
that's for sure uh and
uh and today i was making some money on
oil
it's pretty much the only thing i'm
making money today
i mean on the commodity market
and it's still good so this is i would
say
my
hedge a little bit against the scenario
that
could happen that is a bad scenario that
is
um
that is basically a
a strong bear market that could happen
it's unlikely but it can happen we're in
a situation where it can happen and if
it happens
uh it would probably be due to inflation
that would be caused by the increase of
commodity prices and the commodity of
commodities is oil you need oil for
everything if you want to make gold i
mean yeah even gold you know because you
need oil for the machines
silver uh whatever uh you know
crops uh you need
you always need oil uh for the other to
produce the other commodities so
i'm long oil so at least if there is a
stronger market i'm going to lose money
i can tell you but
this is gonna at least uh protect a
little bit my investment
and it's going to allow me to reload on
the rest of the market at lower levels
i'm going to use this profits if i
manage to make some to reload on the
rest of the market here once again my
target is
145 all right that could be reached
around maybe june
maybe july i don't really know you we
can have different scenarios but i think
that we are heading here so
i'm happy to have this protection
against the rest of the market and i'm
also having a short position on triple
two
i mean it was short then i bought now i
sold again so i'm back with my short
position
it's my short position is increasing on
the on the downside so it's gonna once
again help me to at least uh i'm gonna
i'm still gonna lose money i can tell
you if we move if we keep moving moving
lower but at least i'm gonna be able to
hold my positions and to add uh if we
really go lower which is very important
you always need to keep some of your
investment
if a bad scenario happens because
otherwise you know you're going to find
yourself in a situation where you should
not find yourself you always need to
have a plan for every scenario so this
is my plan i know that whatever happens
um i'm not gonna make money whatever
happens of course but whatever happens
i'm gonna feel good i'm gonna feel like
i'm following my plan which is very
important when you're a trader
especially when you have uh a few days
like i had today and yesterday that are
bad days um you need to you know just
stick to your plan and prepare
everything anticipate and whatever
happens you know what to do you don't
find yourself suddenly in a situation
where uh you are surprised and you panic
and you need to stop your position at
the worst time this won't happen to me
it happened to me in the past i can tell
you it won't happen to me again
so that's it for today guys i hope you
enjoyed this video and if you did please
don't forget to click on the sub like
and bell button so you're gonna be the
first to know when i upload anything new
and stay close to shore see you guys